[Musique]
un amphithéâtre acoustique de 127 places
parfaitement adapté à la pratique du
chant choral jamais la maîtrise de dijon
navette eu des installations aussi
performante et confortable avant son
déménagement ici en 2016
ça ne se voit pas au premier coup d'oeil
il y a des particularités dans le décor
cette mosaïque de bois c'est un mur de
dossiers où sont rangés les partitions
un gain de place
esthétique mais le bois c'est pour le
son des panneaux amovibles permettent de
l'absorber ou le réverbérée
l'architecturé du bâtiment intègre des
astuces dans sa structure et non des
moindres si on voit vial qui a un des
pans de murs qui est courbe et ça permet
en fait de ne pas avoir d'écho et
surtout le bâtiment dans toutes les
pièces
il ya toujours une partie courbes comme
ça le déménagement de la rue du thillot
à ses nouveaux locaux rue lui
nuits-saint-georges compte parmi les
événements qui jalonnent l'histoire de
la maîtrise tout comme la mixité en 1977
aujourd'hui il y a d'ailleurs presque
plus de filles que de garçons
mais ce qui fera date aussi dans les
annales
c'est l'épidémie de koroma virus a
abandonné les vieilles habitudes
beaucoup de choses ont changé à la
rentrée de septembre
la distanciation physique est devenue la
norme une place sur deux dans
l'amphithéâtre ce qui implique du
travail en petits boulots masse et même
quand vous chantez pas comme la
maintenant vous gardez le masque on
enlève le masque uniquement que quand on
chante d'accord
[Musique]
à la pépinière de voix les écoliers
doivent désormais veiller à rester bien
espacés les uns des autres en se
positionnant sur des emplacements
matérialisés au sol il ya peu près tous
les maîtres et le piano est à trois
mètres cinquante et je garde mon masque
si nécessaire et je peux enlever le
masque quand je suis très très loin 2e
derrière le piano
[Musique]
masques pour tout le monde
en cours de solfège des visage sans
expression battent le rythme qui anime
la classe pour la première fois depuis
le confinement la maîtrise s'apprête à
chanter en public pour la messe de
rentrée à la cathédrale saint bénigne
dans un petit local au pied de la
cathédrale
claudette rono à la charge de
l'entretien du vestiaire des maîtrisiens
alors la tenue se compose d'une aube
avec un col blanc qui est lui est
amovible
donc il peut être lavé plus souvent que
l'on m'a surpris avec dollars en coton
blanc avec de la dentelle en bas et
d'une cape à rouge avec un petit col un
petit col vert à la rentrée il ya
beaucoup de travail parce qu'il faut
tous les habits des donc ils sont 70
cette année donc là c'est fait tout est
prêt tout le long de l'année je vais
vérifier les tenues si elles sont bonnes
et assise non pas du tout c'est un petit
souci dessus c'est moi qui n'occupe je
les prépare aussi également avant chaque
messe et avant chaque concert et pour
éviter la pagaille au moment de revêtir
leur tenue
les maîtriser en chacun leur chaise
posée dessus l'art chaussures ce sont
les mêmes depuis plusieurs générations
même chose pour les aubes et les surplis
soigneusement entretenue
dimanche 4 octobre à 8h du matin le chef
de choeur est un peu stressé les
maîtrisiens vont arriver pour la
répétition mais là encore rien ne se
passe comme d'habitude
aujourd'hui c'est très particulière on a
obligé de d'espacer les chaises comme en
plus nous sommes très nombreux on a été
obligé de couper le coeur en deux à deux
endroits différents mais voilà c'est on
a préféré prendre cette vision plutôt
que de faire venir qu'une partie de la
maîtrise pas moins de 120 choristes vont
participer à la messe le grand choeur
les élèves des quatre niveaux du collège
le jeune choeur et le choeur d'hommes